[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to another episode of the random show I
am Kevin rose
I'm Tim Ferriss Tim Ferriss is of course
a best-selling New York Times author
inventor of the term the China virus and
no I'm just kidding perfect true fact
doctor of fact not true fact and we're
we're thrilled dude this is awesome this
is like what a great break from the
chaos than the Hangout it is it is and
it I'll give you credit for the idea of
doing something live which I think at
least for me is very stress reducing and
calming amidst all this uncertainty to
have an actual time where you see your
friends faces and I've not been drinking
at all so it's actually exciting to have
a little bit of boozy boos cheers Kevin
Sirius and everybody out there yes
thanks for joining and well let's let's
perhaps start with what we're what we're
drinking here yeah what are you having
so our mutual friend will Harlan I'm
having the mascot 2012 which is a
fantastic Cabernet Matt a Napa Valley
highly recommend checking out their site
yeah it's called the mascot and it's one
of my favorite caps for sure so this is
something I just pulled it out and I
have no idea where this came from
I didn't buy it so it is whatever that
is I can't pronounce French particularly
well tyd why somebody on to you if you
didn't buy it it was not I mean almost
all of my wine has been given to me and
this just got yanked out so I decided to
go white took a little magnesium three
and eight and l-lysine and a few other
things to mitigate the hangover since I
expect I'll probably finish this during
the session
and we'll see we'll see how that works I
think it could be futile to be too big
to be continued but what other context
should we lay out idle for us well I
think that you know I know that when we
you know you and I will I put together a
document before the the show a little
shared Google Doc and you know we've to
figure out what we're gonna be talking
about in the show and one of the things
that I and we both wanted to address was
just to say you know on a downbeat
before we try and make this a little bit
more of a beach show is just to say our
thoughts are with everyone out there
it's an extremely difficult time and you
know we all have stories of chaos and
craziness and the ups and downs an
emotional roller coaster that's going on
right now in in the world and we know
that there's people that are watching
this that have been laid off there's
people that are watching this that are
that might even be sick or have friends
or family that are sick and you know I
know y'all let you speak for yourself to
him but I know that I mean my thoughts
are with all of you it's it's a really
really difficult time yeah I want to
echo all of that I have family members
who've been laid off I have seen that
amongst a lot of my friends friends I
grew up with and our hearts go out to
everyone and thanks for joining and this
is really aside from the other things
that we might be doing just an attempt
to offer a South even if just for an
hour - yeah - have a feeling of being
connected with other folks Brian
Koppelman who I recently is a friend of
mine co-creator of billions recently had
on a podcast recording has been
published yet but he does something
called the Royale every morning which is
his first cup of coffee takes a picture
and you have other people post their
pictures and it's become this real
vibrant community of people who look
forward to this every day so I figured
at your recommendation Kevin that this
would be a fun experiment just to allow
everybody to hopefully take you know 60
minutes without looking at your Twitter
feed or the bad news
to be plenty of bad news it's still
gonna be there later you don't have to
look at it now and it's been heavy it's
been really heavy I don't know about you
Kevin but I was texting you before we
started recording I have lost and it's
not like I had that much weight to lose
I hate what I've lost
and that well I've lost 15 probably 15
pounds in the last four weeks I've been
in quarantine for five or six weeks but
it's it takes you from it's been
probably I've been I've been eating
pizza and chocolate do like every night
I'm not kidding
well maybe wait well maybe it's that
that energy cannot be created nor
destroyed it just changes form so by me
losing weight I'm just putting it on
your muffin top that that could be your
welcome you'll last longer when we get
to on the like the road or Mad Max
you'll live for a longer time but the
point being like I've been I've been
even when I'm not consciously aware of
it quite under duress and have been
having anxiety dreams and nightmares for
the first time and God knows how long
I've never really had nightmares
consistently and have had I've had
trouble remembering to eat I mean that
sounds crazy and I know some people
might want to have that but it's been a
strange period that's a really strange
period for me and summer a lot of people
I got to say Tim that you were the first
person that was warning me about this
stuff months ago like when it first when
it first kind of broke out and it just
like you know I was trying to gain a
little traction in China like you were
like prepping big-time dude and I
remember I was giving you [ __ ] I was
like ah no man summer will come around
it'll get hotter this will kind of like
die down and you were a hardcore preppin
and you know props you for calling it
early and and what are you doing where
are you are you in a bunker somewhere
like what's going on in Tim's life you
think what is this kind of behind you
like what the hell's going on the decor
is a bit intense
I am using my Scorsese cinematography to
make this look really dramatic I'm in a
guest bedroom because I wanted to be
hard connected the Internet is being
hammered by everyone being home so I
have a tiger king yeah everyone yeah
exactly
pornhub premium so everyone's killing
bandwidth and I have an Ethernet cable
connected and it's just easiest to set
up in the guest yeah I know you have an
Ethernet cable because you called my ass
up so I could walk you in your
[ __ ] Ethernet up I know thank
you - thank you tech support yeah I got
a single PayPal invoice for that - and
I'm in Austin Texas
I am I'm quite happy to be here right
now
my parents are in New York that worries
me of course they're older they're not
in the best of health but there's only
so much as one can do so I want to poke
a little bit into it if I go too far you
let me know but like you know your dad
has been one to want to venture out and
go out and stay and think this is not a
big deal you know you know I've talked
about this privately had convinced him
otherwise like if you convinced him to
stay home and avoid I he he he turned
the corner and I think this is this has
been a common experience for a lot of
folks our age or even younger -
understandably have parents who have
been through many so-called crises who
have been resistant to completely stop
all of what they're doing which i think
is a very understandable position and
then you add in the political polarity
and I don't this is kind of the I
probably wanna go to my degree now we'll
go to greener pastures in a minute but
the point is that he to his credit when
I was able to separate the politics from
the science and talk about the science
you he listened to it and he took it
seriously so I'm perhaps more fortunate
than some in that both my parents are
taking this very seriously just great
and I've got a it's tough because my
mom's gonna be 80 this year and she's um
she's living still by herself but
assisted in that she has to have someone
come by and like help her with
with meal preparation and and things
like that you know she's she needs care
like she can't live on her own anymore
just totally solo and independently but
she's doing well and it's tough because
like you know I was talking to my sister
today
and this Neustadt coming out saying that
you know 20 to 25 percent of people are
asymptomatic and they have no symptoms
at all and I'm like my mom's like hey
you know like when are you gonna see me
and I of course a video with her and
stuff like that but you know I'm like
okay well mom tomorrow if the weather is
okay meaning it's not raining in
Portland I'll come over with a mask on
and sit six feet away from you and we
can have a chat and you know and that
will be the way that I interact with my
mom and it's it's like it's in a way
it's heartbreaking because I have two
young kids and they don't get to see
grandma and they haven't for weeks now
and you know so it's like it it's
stressful for everybody out there man
it's like it doesn't matter who you are
you know it's like everybody's got
something that's that's weighing on them
yeah and then you're locked in the close
quarters with your girlfriend and I'm
locked in closed doors with my wife and
not to say that's that's a bad thing but
it's you know it's unusual to have that
much like straight-up one-on-one time
right house how's that done it's going
well I think it's I think it's like for
those people who haven't been to Burning
Man what they say about couples going to
Burning Man is it's double or nothing
right you're because you're gonna be
with each other 24/7 you're gonna have
all of these additional stresses and I
think we're seeing that now and we've
developed routine part of the benefit if
you want to call it that of having been
in quarantine for almost six weeks now
and I have some pre-existing lung issues
so I've been extra careful but is that
we've we've adopted certain routines and
had these emergent
habits and rituals that have become
really nice actually some of them but
certainly there's more pressure in the
container so if whatever cracks you may
have and everybody has their cracks are
gonna be a lot more obvious yeah and you
know I was talking to a friend of mine
who is saying it's it's like a
magnifying glass that shows you your
psychological Achilles heel so I'm
trying to view that as an opportunity
right as a real opportunity where if
you're at home if you're in quarantine
putting aside financial considerations
which I know are very real for a lot of
people but many people who are watching
this are gonna be safe at home
so you're basically in a sort of a
padded room like a chuck-e-cheese ball
pit where you get to see these things
that are weaknesses / unresolved issues
/ opportunities that you can start to
work on and then will translate to other
areas later yeah in your life and one of
the one of the bullets that we had to
discuss which we could certainly talk
about I'll keep drinking which will
which will give me some liquid
personality and higher confidence which
is dangerous but one of the bullets that
you'd shot over any good books worth
reading now so I'd be cute I'd be
curious to start there cuz I have some
thoughts actually I'll just throw one
out there yeah which which is called
already free and it's by I believe Bruce
Tift TI ft and I I highlight I've
highlighted so much of this book it's
hard to believe it's closely related to
and I'm gonna mention this book to you
already Kevin I think the surrender
experiment or the Michael singer courses
that you've spoken about before
I love Michael senior stuff yeah yeah
it's but this book already free has been
quite impactful
for me and puts puts a lot in
perspectives that's one book that I've
been thinking more about also as I sit
at home and cannot escape myself there
are only so many things you can do to
distract and busier yourself within the
square footage of your house but what
other what other books isn't after
you're related to the psychological
stuff what other books do you think are
perhaps helpful to read or what and what
are you and what are you reading well I
think there's there's two that come to
mind one is is definitely that a lot of
people have had that are fortunate
enough not everyone is in this position
but that are fortunate enough to
transition to online work are you know
having to deal with a whole new set of
tools and a whole new way of working
so Jason freed who I've had on my pot
against if you had him on your podcast
if you had freed on yet I have
yeah but a year and half two years ago
very smart guy I mean just brilliant he
was way ahead of his time in writing the
book remote and he has a couple other
books about remote and distributed
culture that are fantastic definitely
check out the book remote from him if
you have a small business and you're
looking to transition to more remote or
you yourself are going through this it's
a great one to recommend to your boss or
to read yourself that one is definitely
at the top of my list for people I we
have three hundred you know
entrepreneurs that are founders at true
ventures and so that's definitely one
that I'm recommending to a lot of them
Bogle heads guide to investing I think
is another great one and I know it's
it's a it's tough to talk about
investing in times like this but if you
look back historically you know the best
time to place bets and that can be
literally you know tens of dollars
because there's such beautiful things
now that exist such as fractional share
ownership like apps like square cash and
Robin Hood and others allow you to buy
just a fraction of a share if you can't
afford say you know the three hundred
dollar share of you know pick
the major big company out there so Bogle
John Bogle who since passed away is the
founder of Vanguard and he was a big fan
of index investing and so is actually
Warren Buffett and so index investing is
is not picking individual stocks but
buying a market like say like the SP 500
or or you know an index of the bond
market and it really has been proven as
to be is one of the best most reliable
ways to invest in outperforms you know
hedge funds long term it's like in jog
John Bogle the the you know the person
that the the creator of Vanguard was
really the pioneer and coming up with
this concept in creating the mutual fund
index fund mutual funds back way back in
the day anyway that guide Bogle heads
his name's last name is Bogle and his
fans are called Bogle heads so it's a bo
g lae heads guide to investing I think
is a fantastic book and will introduce
you to the concept of index investing
which is is really tried and true and
the best way to go and you know it's a
it's definitely something that was was
someone I read probably a decade ago and
then continued to reread every few years
yeah Joel Joel Greenblatt's books are
also quite good I think it's like the
little blue book investing a little
green book Joel Greenblatt and I I think
he once said to me I don't think I'm
talking out of school by saying this but
that you should effectively read his
books in the opposite order they were
published so read from the most recent
to the oldest the oldest talks a lot
about event based investing which is
very very interesting
exactly somebody I Siegel how to be a
stock market genius terrible title on
some level kind of like the 4-hour
workweek excellent excellent excellent
book and I second Bogle as a
recommendation you know what I've been
paying a lot of attention to Kevin
because it's I can bear markets bull
markets domestic international what is
outperformed almost every other asset
class
can you guess don't say real-estate I
hope you're horny tea porn etf's yeah
but I thought you you're bigger than
that in the marijuana stocks
yeah I'm 5050 porn marijuana that's
portfolio right there yeah pose Diane
rule number one of investing never
underestimate human vice that's not true
that's a lie so what'd you say what was
it no that was it it was just a layup
for a setup for a setup for a joke is
that a poor joke I I will I will say
though on the investing front that no
matter what everyone who is listening to
this or watching this right now I think
should think of themselves as investors
because you have resources you have say
time you have energy you have hours you
have capital and you choose how to
allocate those resources if you have to
choose and you do and not choosing is
also a decision you are an investor and
you're looking for a a a result or a
return on investment from allocating
those different resources you you you
can you can really think like an
investor even if you don't have much
disposable income at the moment or no
income you can still think of yourself
as an investor and hone the thinking the
types of thinking and the process of
good investors and that's where these
books I think are very interesting I
read a lot of these books the books by
Bogle books by Joel Greenblatt I read
his books when I had absolutely same
[ __ ] all I had nothing nothing and it's
been like a slow simmer with that in the
background for a long time and now very
fortunately you and I are in positions
where we can utilize it but we prepared
in a sense beforehand right I mean I was
I was reading books on investing when I
I had not a penny to my name and this is
I think a good
time to even if you don't have money to
invest to read about investing and to
paper trade right and they're probably
absent allow you to do this very easily
but to effectively say all right let's
pretend that I have a thousand dollars
right now or ten thousand dollars where
would I put that money and you make a
record of where you've committed
hypothetically to put that money and
then you align performance over time and
you can look at why you were or if you
were right if you were wrong to what
degree were right or wrong and why you
think you were right or wrong bitcoin
you're more of a crypto expert than I am
I'm not I I know very little of crypto
but I do think it's it's important to
emphasize that the way you end up being
a good investor from my perspective is
by thinking a lot about the types of
decision making that makes a good
investor before you actually start
allocating money to things yeah does
that make sense yeah and I really liked
what you said around in bit like
thinking about how to invest your your
own time during times like this as well
I have two examples of that one I know
someone that is working part time still
has a little bit of income but doesn't
have the other portion of their income
and is now going to take online classes
for as far as they can go to be cummin
erse and he is said this is the perfect
time to do that and I know someone else
has laid off and that was like hey
where's the best coding school that I
can learn how to code and it was like
now's the time Mike I'm gonna be
collecting unemployment for the next few
months there's not gonna be any crazy
great job opportunities but I want to
learn how to code and I can I know that
that can be done in six months time
right so you know it's like that's the
Allens a great time to invest in in
yourself in some sense do you want to
talk about I know you put this in your
newsletter recently maybe today tree
house other options where should people
go yeah I mean there's there's a ton of
options out there I I has Lam just let
Lam
school there's I'm reading comments
people are like Tim Ferriss does
multitask yeah I'm reading your goddamn
comments no it's it's great actually if
people want to post them in the comments
you have free code camp there's a ton
III hesitate to recommend tree house
because I'm an investor there it is a
high quality product but there's a lot
of fun talking his book he's talking his
book don't listen to that guy know what
I mean it's like we get in trouble
anytime we say anything like that so but
the code code Academy is another great
one there's a lot of them here's what I
would say this is the real talk go up
there sign up for three of them and I
figure out which ones you like like take
a couple classes on each one and be like
I mean this instructor is talking to me
more that are speaking to me more than
another one I'm gonna go with this one
and maybe it's a paid one maybe it's a
free one who knows but but try a few
YouTube is also honestly just incredible
I've I know a number of people who have
gotten really up to speed on everything
from biology to options trading on
YouTube and these are these are really
smart people and they've found some of
the best options for free on YouTube
turns YouTube it's a popular thing yeah
I've heard of it I've heard of that
effort that YouTube little later
late to the party but I love the
comments like yes Tim Thank You YouTube
yes love YouTube everybody loves YouTube
too haven't get back yep yeah you're
welcome
I I am the bleeding edge the bleeding
edge of new technology good lord what
else what what else would you find
helpful to read right now Kevin honestly
more what what are you reading what are
you I'm not reading written I'm not
reading I'm what I'm doing right now is
listening to podcasts about the
coronavirus like I think that Peter tia
has converted his podcast the drive into
a fantastic resource for the latest
research on coronavirus with what we
should be doing what happens if you come
down with it what what you know I mean
we all gather a little actually this I
don't know if you're comfortable sharing
like your medical like what would you do
if you didn't talk about that or now
if people want to hear that like what I
do if what if you not came down with it
like what would you write dangerous
dangerous territory yeah I think I think
just by I think if we were to give both
and we're not giving investment advice
we're not registered investment advisors
but I think if we wanted to make this
the perfect Venn diagram of unnecessary
liability that we could talk about
medical but yeah I think it'd be I think
it'd be irresponsible I will say this
that I am optimistic I'm bullish about
therapeutics for coronavirus in other
words treatments that will not
necessarily cure so to speak but
mitigate the severity of kovat 19 I'm
less optimistic about vaccine
development and well at least in the
short term obviously right there's
there's nothing that can short term
meaning 12 to 18 months yeah exactly 12
months would be a miracle yeah be a
world record yeah and it could be I mean
who knows right I mean the US the US if
we're talking about the US and this is
really a global issue but the US is
going to be the largest hotspot in the
world and you see it already is yeah no
I'm just saying like it's going to be we
were looking at maps before we started
recording yeah and you're like this is
gonna look like the horizon it does
availability chart like are the US map
does it's ridiculous yeah I mean we're
gonna be all red so why do you think
that is I have my suspicions but I'm
curious why you think that is and we
don't have to talk about Trump don't
play no no no no no I don't think it has
anything to do I mean I think it is
actually very little to do Trump the
it's it's we're not gonna be all red I
take it back we're gonna be red based on
how the maps are represented because
they make the red circles large based on
the number of cases in a given location
therefore when you zoom out and you look
at a map of the United States even New
York kind of swallows the entire
northeast
so there's there's
there's a challenge kind of Edward Tufte
style in visual representation for that
map but we will be based on how we're
currently representing that data
entirely red based on a distribution
across a say in the short term Miami New
Orleans etc but if you look at the it'll
if you look at the kinetics of the
disease in say Washington compared to
New York is very very different based on
in what's any factors well if you look
at the canoe if you look at the are not
right if you look at the replication of
the virus it's very different based on
population density and the diagonals I
mean right and that's why I wouldn't
expect for instance like I'm not I
wouldn't expect South Dakota to be a
huge however I get that Idaho is not
gonna be massive right right so there
will be in some in some respects fire
breaks between places that could be
hotspots and you know my my expectation
a few weeks ago was that because the US
is loath to impose any strict type of
geographic lockdown that from New York
the places that would explode would be
where all the second homes are from
people who are escaping New York in
other words Nantucket Martha's Vineyard
Connecticut upstate New York Long Island
and Florida right and then you have
event based jumps in cases such as
Spring Break based in Florida plus then
in the returning students say to Texas
44 cases I believe yesterday and then
you have Mardi Gras New Orleans so I'm
extremely happy that South by didn't
happen in Austin helping push that that
was huge yeah my pleasure
it's I shouldn't like a lot shift for it
at the time but I felt pretty confident
in the data but but we're talking a lot
about covet probably I don't know if we
want to keep doing it but the the the
point I was going to make is
therapeutics optimistic vaccine
pessimistic but
I really feel like well I should say
like I'm more optimistic now than I was
four weeks ago about how the US can
recover reasonably quickly and in button
recovers not the right word what I mean
is implement a phased approach to
reintroducing people to jobs so economic
activity so here's my three-step plan if
you will
Oh Kevin's three-step plan well number
one we need to be testing anyone in
everyone my so I have a nanny that helps
with our two kids
she got extremely sick had chest issues
where she couldn't breathe fever the
whole gamut like everything that you
would check is a box of like okay you
have it right she's been home now for a
week and a half she went to the
emergency room two days ago in Portland
Oregon and they would not test her
because she didn't walk in with a fever
she didn't have an active finger we have
to be insanely aggressive about testing
that's one number two people that have
recovered
we need antibody tests and they need to
say I've been recovered and can return
to work we need to know who those people
are and give them the green light to go
back and help start things up again
right like I think that's insanely
important and we also like one of the
things that we need to be good is it's
like really and this is gonna be more
important six eight months from now is
really when we do see a flare-up like do
that contact tracing and really telling
people to lock down because this is not
just gonna go away like it's gonna keep
we're gonna have flare up after flare up
after flare up we have to make sure that
we're really gues aggressive about
contact tracing and making sure that
people stay home if they've been in
contact with someone that's impacted
yeah yeah I I've been on text and the
phone quite a bit today with two
different groups for developing digital
contact tracing
technologies and they're all there are
already a number of apps that have been
developed for instance in Singapore that
work very well and Singapore is kind of
like New Zealand in the sense that it's
pretty small it's self-contained yeah
and it makes for a good laboratory so I
am optimistic that if there are phased
steps put in place with enforcement that
is in all caps with enforcement and
penalties for those who do not comply
did you see the people with sticks in
India to stay in the dead
yeah yeah we could yeah that United
States like there yeah like dudes on
scooters like hitting people with rods
to stay inside like that yeah yeah as
much as I would like to do that there
are criminal penalties and Nepal similar
story there's something be said about
that though man like that they get
people to stay in you know like and it
wasn't like they were like beating them
more like they're breaking bones like
it's like just like I like a bad
spanking like it's it's weird but I made
a really bad spanking these are like bo
staffs but the the you know the X Factor
for me is a non-compliant population in
the United States and by design and if I
like cultural evolution a defiant
disobedient population and we shall see
how a politically divided country is
able to implement or not implement
strict basically I mean the less strict
we are in the next month or two the
longer this is gonna last
sure right and you have a lot of
perverse incentives involved with say
folks who are hoping for re-election and
if it's a short-term reelection they're
willing
to make compromises for public health in
order to at least appear as though
they're attempting to reinvigorate the
economy to serve their political
interests which is disgusting but
totally understandable
and really I think a lot of it has to
come and I don't know if it can
illegally at least at this point from
the federal level there have to be
really really strict penalties for
violation of breaking say home
quarantine or isolation rules in Korea
it escalated from like four to eight
thousand dollars a US and the equivalent
in one in where was it someplace I can't
recall
maybe the philippi mm maybe the
Philippines actually I can pull it up
here let me tell you said that those who
violate the lockdown orders could be
shot that is a lot more for us to hear
in the States
yeah Philippines Philippines president
says violators of lockdown measures
could be shot not saying that's all I'm
not saying yet China China's Schengen
also banned cat and dog meat consumption
that's a separate story the chat says
Spain fines up to thirty thousand
dollars you know that's so dollars i I
do think that without punishment slash
Awards that a lot of this wishful thing
UK is thirty pounds as if somebody said
30 yeah 30 pounds just like it's a
[ __ ] joke I mean come on
so in any case what are you doing with
Nick front do you have like a freezer
full of [ __ ] or what are you doing oh
yeah yeah
I mean I'm fully like bison ship you
have like crazy meats yeah I've accessed
here I've got venison I think I have I
have hundreds of pounds of meat and holy
crap think I could possibly need so
we're saying this Joe Rogan Styles with
the people said in the comments
yeah Rogan's Rogen's got his elk I have
my ax
I've got my axis deer
and people are asking what type of wine
glasses is it's called zalto za LT oh oh
you got the fancy [ __ ] yeah I've got
whatever these Costco bumbling idiot
uncoordinated person wine glasses are
without the stem that's my that's my jam
those are easy easy cleaning
you just throw those in the dishwasher
ah let's see let me let me look at some
questionnaires Tim do you live in a
high-rise or a house I live in a house
Tim please check your wine said I carry
one two three I'm not gonna check my
wine No thank you I'm no longer I'm no
longer eighteen is now an ideal ideal
time to adopt dog I would actually like
to speak to this for a second a lot of
people are adopting dogs just as an
excuse to be able to get outside that's
actually something that's been seen in
New York City for instance where lots of
people are adopting dogs who I am not
convinced to have a long-term intention
of keeping said dogs that [ __ ]
bothers me having grown up on Long
Island where city people no offense to
Manhattanites would come out adopt a dog
for the summer just to keep their kids
occupied and then put their dog back in
the pound at the end of the summer and
that in my opinion is [ __ ] I think you
are morally corrupt if you do such
things so is it the ideal time to adopt
a dog if you're going to keep that dog
and you're going to make your life fit
around the dog not the other way around
then I would say consider it yeah the
ones you return to a real selfish prick
when you return to work if you're if
you're like leaving your dog at home for
extended periods of time that's that's
not cool they need interaction and love
and attention all that good question for
you Kevin I got beakers to your thoughts
on this so investing question betterment
slash wealthfront versus investing stray
and Vanguard yeah I mean think about
that's hard I well I'm an investor in in
wealthfront so and I put that out my
newsletter today admit me to me to
invest as well so you know I think
honestly though I have used better many
things great product I think well
friends great - I like the risk parity
part that wealthfront offers
and I've used Vanguard as well just like
straight-up Vanguard to buy stuff and
it's fine so I would say research them
all and do whatever you're comfortable
with that is the most lawyer responsible
dude I don't want to like it's like it's
self-serving you say go use wealthfront
I love them that's why I invested I
think it's a great yeah I know but what
do you like about them well it's the
risk parity they have this this special
what does that mean well it's it's a
fancy thing that like really expensive
hedge funds use to get better returns
and they offer it to their clients which
is normally not something you would get
at a unless you had a lot of money to
invest and I love that they're taking
that and dropping that down and making
it more accessible to most people so
that's yeah if they do a lot of the
harvesting tax-loss harvesting which I
think in so does better minutes which is
great it's just these Robo advisors are
so much smarter than your traditional
like classic adviser you call on the
phone that's gonna you know make changes
for you once a year or twice a year I
think they're optimizing using
algorithms for taxes and a whole slew
different things so forget the fact that
we're saying we both invest in
wealthfront like a robo advisor in
general is going to be a better
performing adviser for you than the most
individual and advisors that are out
there couple questions Mulligan 26
coping advice with single room
quarantine for two weeks
single room oh my god yeah I would say
exercise number one why and for sure why
it's honest and and that then leads to
Granberry Tim what's your favorite
bodyweight workout routine gymnastic
body or gymnastic bodies that's coach
summer
Christopher summer Somm ER his program
is just fantastic
I highly recommend yeah let's talk about
working at working out for a sec because
I think that's a good one a lot of
people are turning towards that I will
say two things one I'm not invested in
this company so I could say this freely
fit bod I've been using lately if you
have free weights at home or you're just
doing bodyweight workouts they have a
great app I know it's on iOS I don't
know if it's in Android I think it is
it's called fit be OD I've been using
that for my free weights that I have
here at the house peloton is my main
form of cardiovascular exercise and they
also have other classes they're actually
giving away 90 days of their app as well
which is a larger of disclosure what I
why I own peloton stock it so do you do
you know i don't i but i'm looking at it
very closely but i do not yet they have
they have actually sponsored your
podcasts which you didn't mention which
i'm a little offended by that's true
peloton has sponsored my podcasts i have
one upstairs
I do love love me my peloton i I got you
into that yeah you did
you didn't you totally did you and Marc
Benioff got me into peloton I love how
the peloton story about I I so Tim was
like I'm not gonna tell you my peloton
account because I wanted to race you
right because you can do these you're
like you're like I'm like give me my
username blah blah and I emailed your
assistant and I was like hey what's up I
just want to check on Tim's user name
for his palate on account cuz I want to
like friend him up or whatever if she
sent me your login information with your
password do you remember that it was me
I do I was very unhappy about that I
told you I memorize like Tim do not fire
her do not be upset she didn't know but
she sent me your entire peloton pocket
is just [ __ ] like social engineering
lay up just like casual walk down the
court lay up I love it is good lord
let's see beer with I'm looking at some
of these we're looking at comments
questions three fiction books you would
gift to each other that's a good
question Martin sang gay 3 fiction books
well I know Kevin can't spell so I
assume his reading level is probably 6
or 7th grade so based on that first of
all I would have a learning disability
so Paul what is your learning disability
lazy smelling no I'm just not a good
speller I've had issues sometimes they
get the the letters swapped and I love
grammarly Grimley is a great product
help
me out there but I'm just saying if you
want to make fun of people with learning
disabilities I get it like but that's no
I little talk'd oh I always have had a
little bit of an issue with that it's
it's nothing I can memorize like it's
it's a it's a brain thing something's up
that I think you just type with your
knuckles on your iPhone but we can take
this
so exhalation line by the way exhalation
100% agrees yes fantastic series of
short fiction books that are amazing
highly recommend so gay exhalation is
outrageously good another one if you
haven't read it I think everyone should
read doom by Frank Herbert it's just one
of the best worlds building fiction
books of all time now Daria is my wife's
favorites it's like oh it's so good if
you want if you want to basically learn
let's just say 90% of the lessons of
leadership that you would get from
reading up a hundred of the best
business books non-fiction on leadership
just read in it's so good I love that
book so I should get that on I do a lot
of audible the shy is it good on audible
or I'm sure it's good it'll just take
you like six years it's like I started
Sheldon I started Shogun inaudible it's
like you will complete careers yeah sure
that's also incredible so far so good
man it's amazing
yeah Shogun is is also exceptional I
would say what else would you recommend
for fiction I mean I've been getting
back into fiction I think fiction is
very medicinal has a therapeutic value
guys during times like this I really do
I'm reading a book called little big
little comma big right now which is a
it's a difficult read it the prose is so
beautiful but it requires concentration
and if you can commit to 50 pages of it
you will probably buy in but it's it's
an effort it's not as easy to read you
to say Kurt
or like cat's cradle by Kurt Vonnegut
right it's just an incredible book it's
easy to read he's hilarious that's an
easy fiction book to read when to you
would you dive into something like that
what what gives you the space mentally
because like for me
if I'm doing some fiction it's very
casual I've had a glass of wine and I'm
chilling
Daria doesn't have anything else to do I
put in my you know air pods and I just
like just zone out a little bit it's
just like fun but I don't want to like
be really thinking serious about
something like when do you do that
you know recently just this is just in
the last handful of days I've been
reading a little big whenever I feel
anxious and as though I can't stop in
the sense that if I have a to-do list in
front of me of things I've somehow
convinced myself are of great importance
and I can't stop and I need to rush to
lunch or whatever it might be that to me
is a signal of scarcity and faulty
thinking so today for instance I did
this I took two breaks and just read for
10 or 15 minutes as a way to calm my
nerves and I've been using it that way
this book a little big also is one of
those books where for instance if you if
you read the Baron and the trees by
Italo Calvino which is an incredible
book the Baron and the trees there are
only a handful of characters so you can
stop reading the book for a week pick it
back up and you're fine little big is so
complex and there's so many characters
and there's a really difficult family
tree involved that you cannot put this
book down for a week you'll be totally
totally [ __ ] lost so you really have
to read a little bit every day yeah
right now right now for me I like yeah I
like that that there's that incentive
try a little bit gin like I typically
hate those types of books like Game of
Thrones you're like okay they're
introducing like the forty second
character
you're like okay yeah yeah yeah Dave I
can't even say this day Dave Inc sidon
see something like that
recommended Zorba the Greek I think is
over the Greek is a fantastic book that
is actually a great book to read right
now because really contrast this type a
control freak with this freewheeling
epicurean Zorba that is a great great
great book I would say I would suggest
somebody just said the TJ Rivera doing
this excellent inaudible which I would
[ __ ] oscillate because this is such a
clot such a classic fears the mind
killer yes the Bennett Jesuit litany
against fear I've got it I've got a
question for you Tim that now that we're
a couple of glasses deep or I think I
use every drink two glasses or no I'm
about yeah 3/4 of a bottle gone so I'd
say yes all right so I'm curious like
you mentioned a minute ago about you
know when you need a break to go and and
read this book right like you like the
stress kind of thing what is what's
bothering you because I think most
people like watching this would think
you've got it all very successful yeah
plenty of money like get held up totally
Clooney of bison like what is it yeah
but like really what is it that's like
what's getting under your skin like
what's bothering you these days yeah
well that presupposes that I know what
it is that's bothering me interesting so
I would say plenty of ayahuasca journeys
to even things out a little bit yeah
don't do that don't do that i man we
could talk about that separately we
could talk about that if you like but
ayahuasca is a big gun I don't I don't
recommend that for everyone by actually
recommend it for a very very small
percentage of people but the the
this period of time and this amount of
uncertainty and the heightened fear that
many people are feeling I think brings
to the forefront whatever it is that you
haven't dealt with mmm whatever it is
you haven't processed and I spent much
of my life numbing myself and turning
off sensitivities in the last few years
have have entailed me turning back on
many sensitivities and I I think
fundamentally I'm a very sensitive
person and that doesn't mean that I'm
easily offended I mean sensitive like an
instrument like a jewelry scale versus a
body weight skill and the it's
interesting you mention that I've
noticed that about you dude to be honest
like I've known you for a while now
quite a while know me for more than a
decade yeah and I would say that when I
first met you you were very hardened you
know and you've softened a lot and you
become in a more fragile in and I mean
that in a way of like it's actually a
stronger position to be in someone that
can actually talk about what's going on
and that wasn't the case ten years ago
it definitely was not the case ten years
ago yeah I appreciate you saying that
man I'm more a beautiful thing is I feel
like I've kind of gone through a similar
transformation so it's you you
definitely have you definitely have I've
I've become more porous and permeable in
so much as I've taken a lot of armor off
and armor is helpful in some ways in the
sense that it keeps things out it also
keeps a lot trapped within when you take
the armor off then you're exposed to
more and so perhaps ten years ago the
weight of the world and all these deaths
and all the unemployment wouldn't have
affected me very much but it's affected
me a lot in the last few weeks
and so I think there's a mourning period
that I'm going through that has been
very emotionally difficult I'm not
worried about me personally right like
financially who the [ __ ] cares I mean I
and I and I say that in such a way very
deliberately because if I were to try to
spin some type of woe is me story it
would be so [ __ ] absurd that I want
you Kevin to like slap me through the
[ __ ] internet because you and I are
both very very fortunate and we've also
worked very hard and made some good
decisions but we've also had a lot of
luck a ton of hand ton of luck and so so
I am in I am in a good position I'm in a
good position to help my family but the
the stuff that is being brought up is
largely things I can't identify these
are the things from my past things from
my childhood probably that are causing a
level of anxiety in the face of
uncertainty that has no basis in my
current security does that make sense
like I I'm not worried about my mortgage
payment I'm not worried about my food
but nonetheless I have this high level
of anxiety at times last few days have
been quite good I've actually felt
pretty good the last few days but there
are these moments when I'll go to bed
I'm exhausted at the end of every day
these days I'm completely spent and I'll
go to bed and I'll lay in bed and all of
a sudden I'm tired and wired and my mind
is just producing a million thoughts a
second that are all kind of anxiety
driven and I don't have an explanation
for it I just don't have a clean and
that that itself has to drive more
anxiety right because you're like why
can't I figure out what it is that's
bothering me
you know yeah yeah totally so I the
thing yeah yeah no please I was just
gonna say the the since you're sharing
all this like the thing that
worries me the most is one I think it's
hard because I see my sister not having
the work that she used to and so that's
challenging and and I see her struggles
with her she's a single mom and she is
trying to raise some teenager now at
home and it's challenging you know
working like being a teacher at home now
and my mom who is 80 now so those those
things are both weighing on me but I
would say honestly like the thing that
scares and mouth is not not me getting
this or not be getting sick from me cuz
they you know random people our age do
die from this right it's like it's kind
of weird like that like you know it's
like you think you're fine and then you
know you're 40 I'm 42 and I get hit or
43 and they get hit and I'm just like
dead right like it is happening so I'm
not scared of dying at all actually I'm
scared of not seeing and being able to
talk to my girls when they're gonna need
it most like through their formative
years and I think that is the thing that
at my core I just like I love my girls
so much I wouldn't want to miss out on
that and so that it's not the death part
it's the it's it's that part so it's
it's hard it's like we all have these
these things that are kind of like
hanging over our head so you know it's
difficult yeah
what if you found helpful oh gosh well
half bottle wine definitely helps I
would say no I would say helpful yeah
mine might have might have to make this
a weekly thing you know honestly this
could be our weekly therapy honestly
helpful
first and foremost without a doubt is
and this is mr. Rogers definitely said
it best I mentions in my news letter
like anything that is human is
mentionable and anything that is
mentionable is manageable and that is so
true like if you could just talk about
it with your spouse with your friend
with anyone that you can try and create
a social connection with and just be
like this is what I'm going through just
getting that off your chest is just like
brings you down doesn't get you back to
where you want to be like perfect and
happy
like so stoked and you know but it does
bring you down a couple notches and we
just have to remember to do that every
few days just like like where did you
get that quote was that mr. Raja no I
know it's [ __ ] Mister Rogers but was
it from the documentary about him or was
it from an excursion was it was
something else
it was from the Tom Hanks version which
I loved and and I went and did then did
a research to actually make sure it was
from him and not just like Hollywood and
it did come from him so the Tom Hanks
movie was phenomenal it's available for
rent now you can get on Amazon iTunes it
is it's a great it's a great movie it's
yeah it's not Tiger king or the
technique is pretty great hey we should
talk about this let's move into a hold
on before we get before we get Tiger
gang so somebody suggested or they just
mentioned how to stop worrying and start
living that's a Dale Carnegie book that
is [ __ ] fantastic I could not
recommend it more it has very literal
title as do many Dale Carnegie books but
how does how to stop worrying and start
living is is actually an exceptional
exceptional book so I would suggest
that's awesome we got a book create a
well we're saving the video for this so
I guess we can do some show notes and
stuff for all the stuff we talked about
and imposed online yeah so you were
about to bring up what what we're
watching yeah what are we watching
lately quick what are people watching
these days like favorite tiger King is
like my favorite thing right now I'm
gonna have a selfie yep yep so we'll get
into that real quick a Buchi says the
people rego conscious maybe underlying
the anxiety that's not accurate I don't
actually fear death which may be from
taking too many second Delic compounds
but that's not it it's something else
so TBD but let's see here people are
saying Ozark by the way is that how you
say it was arc like I I have heard
multiple people it's on episode or a
season three now if that's right people
will correct me in the chat is it
awesome people are saying Ozark is
awesome
as incredible shark Tiger King was good
I found the animal treatment depressing
so I stopped after two episodes I make I
may continue but that hasn't been my
go-to one of them your but but you told
me tell me that yeah but but but maybe I
haven't passed like the point of no
return with Tiger king it is it is so
strange as to be compelling yeah I get
that yeah
Daria watch it with me I'm watching a
solo I said and out my iPad when I watch
it she won't she will not watch it when
I she missed the first episode and that
she's like I don't want to watch
something dumb and I'm like it's dumb
but it's coming good you know the the
three-person marriage with that one
young guy looking like he was [ __ ]
gout with this bad mind was amazing so
good and then she definitely fed her
husband to the Tigers it's I mean that
seems to be at least the way that that's
going you just want it to show yeah I
mean that's that's pretty crazy people
are saying formula 1 what is formula 1
formula 1 I understand what it is in
terms of like uterus Gia's favorite
thing ever
yeah Racing race car sees in a
documentary that people are talking
about or like oh I don't know I assume
that it's some kind of like Skyy yes f1
on that for you I don't get it guys I'm
sorry like I I can appreciate how
difficult it is I can appreciate how the
Mercedes team spends like five hundred
million a year yep I can appreciate all
of that but like I don't actually know
how to discern the skill from watching
these cars go right here's the
interesting thing people are saying that
this is so amazing
like everyone's saying formula 1 f1 f1
like if it's a documentary like why not
watch an episode of it that sounds like
what's not into it either
watch the documentary Senna sen na it's
[ __ ] fantastic it's so good is it's
highly recommended that people aren't
saying them they're saying Formula One
in the chat they don't know there's they
don't know what they're talking about if
they actually follow f1
then they would agree with Senna Peter
Atia so his favorite driver of all time
is Ayrton Senna yeah and the documentary
is just fantastic I highly highly
recommend what else she watching besides
time cooking I don't watch it I don't
watch TV we don't watch I'm being dead
serious we don't I'm like if people
really want to know the real me I will
tell you the truth I we don't watch any
TV we watch I love MBA I will watch
basketball if my team is doing well
which is the Green Bay Packers I will
watch some football even though I'm kind
of conflicted there because of the head
injury stuff and I would say that I
watch movies like if there's like I
watched the new Star Wars I thought it
was great I don't know why people hated
on it I didn't watch it in the theater I
just watched it when it came out you
know I rented it and thought I was
amazing but I'm not we're not huge TV
people you watched me chat TV yes I'm
watching this chat TV what's up are you
talking about TV selling you have
coaxial cables coming out into some name
tube TV I use that as my main TV I don't
have any more you watch basketball in
movies that's very ungratified what
movies do you watch do basketball it was
amazing by the way it's like one of the
best sports out there and movies I would
say I watch contagion recently which is
have you not seen contagion uplifting
yeah have you seen it I have seen
contagion yes yeah it's really scary
it's it's like no but it's like really
crazy how it's like so like a it's kind
of like what's happening right now it's
it's it's kind of nuts but yeah I mean
if there's an occasional movie that
comes out that is awesome all I'll put
it on okay I'm watching the amazing mrs.
Mazal yes you were saying a meet you
were trying to get me to watch that like
caboose go I think it's hilarious it's
great and that is our week day meaning
my girlfriend and I watch this one
weakness we differentiate between week
days and week and you guys are so crazy
you have so many rules it's super
helpful
to tell about you can't talk about kovin
for more than certain number of hours
well no I mean I think this is a good
good rule actually so it's been
difficult to enforce but I try and it's
been encouraged to very strongly to not
talk about kovat after dinner hours and
we have dinner together almost every
night and we would light a candle that's
very romantic we open the sliding doors
so we can hear some of the sounds from
nature usually this is around say 6:30 7
o'clock tonight is an exception so we
[ __ ] with Kevin on the internet with
her however many thousand closest
friends and so that's one guideline that
we haven't been following very closely
but actually it's been better in the
last few weeks so I'm so early on this
that I feel like I've distributed my
anxiety there's evenly over a long
period of time whereas you were on the
phone with me and you're like I can't
talk about Cove hit that guy I passed
that hard I passed I passed the time
when I was supposed to be talking about
it I was like what are you talking about
dude yeah I think I think it's I think
it's I think it's very reasonable of my
girlfriend and not want me to talk about
[ __ ] Cove it past a certain hour but
but we we often exercise in the morning
that's one ritual we also then have
dinner tonight or not tonight but almost
every night together someone asked about
best meal made during quarantine we
really like butternut not fun and I
always say that spaghetti squash which
can be cleaned it can be disinfected
very easily the Rhine is thick plus
ground access dear Plus tomato sauce
garlic oregano and a few other things
it's [ __ ] amazing as oh it's so good
it's just unbelievably good so that
that's one then the differentiation
between weak
and weekends I think is actually quite
important because when every day can be
Groundhog Day
it is psychologically a reprieve when
you can delineate or provide breakpoints
and sort of open chapter closed chapter
on a weekly basis so for us that means
that on the weekends we watch movies or
we watch something that is not our
primary weekdays series which currently
is the amazing mrs. Mazal so last
weekend for instance we binge watched
some of season two of Westworld
and there are a number of documentaries
that we may end up watching but we'll
reserve the amazing mrs. Mazal for
weekdays and it's been it's been helpful
it's been it's it's just helpful in a
world of uncertainty to have rules and
certainty related to certain things and
I'm sure that some folks will find that
ridiculous
I'm sure someone find it very helpful I
think we find out for I think what you
said around it being Groundhog Day rings
true for a lot of people and that
because we are all quarantined it is
like kind of the same thing you know
over and over again and one of the
things that Daria my wife like said it
was like I wanted like last night was
our seven-year wedding anniversary
and she's that's been thank you and she
was like I want to dress up like I'm one
of like I know we're sitting across from
each other at home but I want to put on
something really nice and I'm like okay
same here like I'm gonna put down and
I'm like a nice button-down shirt and
like do it proper because like you know
it's you kind of have to like say let's
not just fall into the same thing every
single time and I think the schedule
could help with with things like that
you know like to change it up a bit yeah
so what do you guys do you got you took
off your under is your onesie and you
got dressed up what do you guys do for
your anniversary which is [ __ ] crazy
by the way it shows you how long we've
known each other
yeah I because that doesn't seem that
long ago and I remember being at the
wedding seven years that's nuts
and that's crazy man it's crazy it's
it's been an amazing adventure and I've
learned a lot but I would say that yeah
I mean we just basically had dinner I'm
just kind of hung out at the house I
mean there's not like a lot to do you
know it's like yeah what are you gonna
do other than just like having them we
had like a nice little meal and some
dessert which we don't normally do and a
little dude don't don't even start with
the no dessert I've seen you when I stay
at your place with my girlfriend not too
long ago I remember we came back from
dinner you were washing off pot you're
apologizing off pints of ice cream
listen you hit that ice cream too we
shared a pint and you killed most of it
and that was good ice cream it was good
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna accept the I
killed most of it I did take the like
beggars we eat some out of Dover's
that's true we did we hit the ice cream
hard which facilitates the ice cream
that was amazing ice cream by the way
yeah yeah it's really good they make
good ice cream in in Portland Oregon
people are saying truth comes out in the
comments it's legal people it's legal
it's legal what is what is some straws
that the ice cream company yeah it is
not the one that we had but it is it is
one of the best in Portland for sure as
Tim's Jewish ashed Noah Johnson I don't
know what my position on weed was so
it's hard for me to say I mean your
answer has changed I'm not anti weed I
just kidding a lot of weed makes me
[ __ ] paranoid so don't enjoy taking
it all right the woot bands know I've
had issues with the whoo band man I had
a blast
what the hell is that it's like a Fitbit
fancy Fitbit and I I want to
do you remember this yeah I do remember
that what the whoop or the weed yeah
yeah yeah yeah no the whoop okay
no no weed right now
I actually do use weed will calm you
dude
Thanks sip Azhar I do use full-spectrum
CBD oil for sleep where do you get that
from I don't remember the brand's I like
the pure encapsulations full-spectrum
CBD which is quite nice that might be
what I have actually yeah yeah they make
a good one it's like 10 or 20 milligrams
per thing let's go for it
Tim do you still ride your boosted board
absolutely not because I view it as
suicidal for me at the moment it's just
too fast like the the speed limiter on
it is exceptionally high so I have very
little confidence in my ability to do a
stop drop and roll if I wipe out at 20
miles an hour how did I lose 15 pounds
yeah like client Giants eom asks by
forgetting to eat because I'm too
[ __ ] stressed out I don't recommend
that as a diet approach necessarily more
sleep recommendations having troubles
Groundhog des and meddler what
recommendations might you have yeah so
sleep is definitely something I've spent
a lot of time playing around with yeah I
think max has a great point here max
goldberg matt walker's book why we slept
is a phenomenal resource for this stuff
that said I've done low-dose melatonin
and also the magnesium is the one that
you recommended to him at the beginning
of the show mag teen yeah that's a and
Aria these are you know my wife she
takes that every night she takes the one
that's from a brand called live on which
is a liposomal form and and she swears
by it like she looks she loves it all
all the roid monsters love live on do
they really why oh yeah for
liver recovery after taking their alpha
alkylated oral anabolics so what do they
take the liver recover what what camera
or the actuals they do about addict they
do a vitality they do a my museum yeah
they they have a liver product that was
really gonna put them on the map
yep absolutely I also use their
liposomal vitamin C I do too
that's my favorite vitamin C tastes like
horse semen but you know I've never had
horse semen but I would imagine that is
probably similar you have yeah you have
no you have house if you had live on
vitamin C the nutritional crazy stuff
for your house and for our chef had some
I think there was a recipe with in there
with horse semen that you know all my
books I think the most appropriate right
now for quarantine is the 4-hour chef it
is I'm drunk enough to say this it is
the perfect book for quarantine it
really is it inaudible no cuz it make no
[ __ ] so that would be amazing about
like just hearing you being like one
baking soda man what else do we have in
the comments let me take a look at our
list of things that we wanted to cover
because I have to dive in I'll look at
the comments you look at our list apps
we've been using I think we've kind of
covered that shows we've been talking
about I think we covered everything we
want to talk about is there anything
else that people want us to talk about
sure there'll be no shortage here Macha
for men any new drawings Tim wim hof Oh
Kyle it bounce will you guys do this
again I don't know what do you think
Kevin it's been fun
I would love to yeah to continue your
time yeah especially if this this kind
of craziness continues which I'm imagine
it would like it'd be fun to do this
every every few weeks you know make it
monthly yeah I think mothers you find as
that's that's a good idea
cool any should we do any parting notes
or any like any things that we want to
say on the way out how was the stream
quality I'm curious for people was it
good
great great good awesome
I'm glad this worked out because here's
the funny thing I went on to zoom and
Tim is like how are we gonna do this
like let's figure it out and I went into
zoom and they had a what they call what
did they call it the what is the account
called where like you know the webinar
account as I go we'll do a webinar with
zoom is supports up to ten thousand
people and remember I sent you the price
it's ten grand
it's ten grand for zoom webinar for ten
thousand people yeah it's crazy
it's a lot of money so thankfully
obviously we know Bennett Bennett Caffey
and the CEO and he offered to do this
and bettan Ben's great even though they
almost killed me scary that that's a
side note yep side note all right
whoever if you want to look up tomahawk
skiing accident that'll give you a nice
image of what it looked like as I
catapulted myself headfirst down many
steep inclines with our dear friend Penn
yeah he's a big snowboarder he was very
good right was he's no he's much better
at snowboarding that I am at skiing
which led to the disparity and
confidence when we went down cornices
and I ended up tomahawking head over
heels over and over again Tim sounds
like is peanut butter stuck to the roof
of his mouth
Eric Kaplan that's because I've had a
glass of wine more than festive wine
let's do some parting parting thoughts
what are your parting bottles Donnie
bottle bottle of one you know when they
do that yeah yeah I feel like you have
an urgency to your escape photos I live
broadcasts I know that we have we arms
drummer at some point I'm struck
that was amazing whoever said Tom's drug
it's got 13 for 16 hearts now 24 37 40
wow that person's Hamed Slayer
soundtrack during isolation Tim
blood-red blood
great workout trash they're so good
raining blood yes random Bloods pretty
intense yeah that whole album is very
intense but I have a side workout that
includes old Metallica and Slayer it's
it's good stuff man on [ __ ] white
wine who gets drunk on white wine
Geoffrey that's a good point
Keith Tim Farriss that's who because you
know why because I can
that's why random drug show alright so
let's do some parting thoughts here
before we go alright alright you want to
start no [ __ ] no alright I'll start I
know it's tough give us a Gettysburg
Address I want to hear something
profound Kevin now there's a nothing
profound other than one I want to thank
everybody for showing up tonight it's
nice to have a little break from the
chaos
obviously in Tim thank you for agreeing
to do this because it's it's just uh
it's tough times and I think that you
know we've seen this this this type of
thing impact everyone that we know and
it doesn't matter how rich you are like
or how poor you are like it's it's
hitting everyone in a different way and
I just wanted to know I just wanted to
everyone out there that my my thoughts
are with all of you I know it's this is
gonna be a challenging few years so we
will get through it together and
hopefully with a little bit of comedy
and some random shows every now and then
and our podcasts that we do and you know
I just want to encourage everyone to to
be safe and to quarantine as much as
possible stay home like I'm doing
grocery want runs once a week now I have
a little bit of stockpiled food but I
also go out to the grocery store and you
know there's no shame in in wearing
gloves or wearing a mask or it's
like it's it's real so I just wanted to
give much love to all the people
watching this you're happy mr. rose I
would say to add to that that thanks for
heavy things are heavy right now and we
will get through this even if if this is
as Bill Gates would perhaps propose the
once in the century pandemic the the
human species in without the hominids
that we are have existed for a very long
time and we have made it through many
pandemics many epidemics over time and
we will make it through this one and it
is your job in a way now that natural
selection and Darwinism are in full
force once again to not kill yourself
and not kill other people and I would
suggest that you as Kevin said stay home
as much as possible wear masks the masks
do help despite what's what the World
Health Organization might lead you to
believe that's yeah it's [ __ ]
nonsense masks help period end of story
especially for a a cinematic sorry to
interrupt but like if you know people
most people don't know they have it and
that's a year yeah yeah and so one way
to think about this is not just how do
you protect yourself but how would you
act if you had kovat 19 if you were
positive how would you act so you would
not contaminate anyone else and there
are a lot of ways to work around that if
you need to do grocery runs you could
consider using a TaskRabbit for instance
who's already going to be exposing
themselves how can you piggyback on
other activities etc and so on but
I would say it's very helpful at times
like this when we're so mired in the
weeds and so overwhelmed and so perhaps
stressed in the face of uncertainty to
zoom out and if you zoom out you could
look at a book like I believe it is the
lessons of history by William and Ariel
Durant and when you read a book like
that which effectively takes 10,000
pages of documentation Jesus it is
already ready a synopsis and then
concentrates it down to about 120 pages
that's not bad yeah then you realize how
common what we're going through is when
placed in the context of a broader human
history and for that reason you know
there is reason to be careful there's
reason to be cautious and strategic but
humans will exist after this it I
suspect it will be sooner than people
expect in terms of economic recovery and
as it stands right now I think the most
important thing is to take this
seriously
now so that it doesn't extend over 18 to
24 months the more seriously you take it
now the less seriously you can take it
12 months from now and that that I think
is worth highlighting so that's what I'd
say I also extend my heart and empathy
to all those who are suffering right now
with job loss with economic uncertainty
and so on it's a [ __ ] hard time and
hopefully every everyone can do a little
bit to help the handful of people all
right
them you don't need to save the world
but if there's a barber or a dog walker
or a coffee shop or someone near you who
you can reach out to just to simply ask
what can I do to help is there anything
I can do to help that's a major public
service and karmically you will be
adding a lot to your bank account
for the final tally so that's that's
what I would say sometimes help is just
having a conversation with someone just
giving them to a chance to vent and get
things off their chest you know 100
percent the one thing I will say that
when you were talking to him they were
coming up in the comments is that people
were saying masks are not available and
I will say that I did see a very
interesting it was an article I actually
heard it on on the radio when I was
driving in in the car it was talking
about alternatives to the masks that
people are using and they have found
that sewing fabric like multi-layered
fabric like like cotton masks and even
scarves and other things anything you
can do to cover your mouth and nose is
effective is it gonna be clinical grey
like maybe not but you know there's no
shame in going to the grocery store with
a scarf of your mouth like there's the
there's these are difficult times and we
got to just make do with what we have so
I you know it's like I'm I'm doing the
same thing it's like it's it's it's
tough but we in tell those become
available to the general public it's
like we gonna do the best we can yeah
something is better than nothing
100% at this point so number one you
know I would say duty can be responsible
think about not just your safety but the
safety of those near community and also
try to be easy on herself right nobody's
[ __ ] ace in this right now nobody is
we're all [ __ ] scared yeah
nobody's acing this it's like I got a 80
year old mom that I'm freaking out about
every single day because she goes out
and checks the mail by herself and
touches her mail and I'm like maybe you
shouldn't be doing that like there's
things like you know little tiny holes
and all this stuff
like my mom's got really really really
bad asthma and so it's like a done done
deal she gets us in this game over and
inside yeah it's just you know we all
are struggling here in some capacity and
I know some more so than others so if
you have this or you know someone that
haves it we're rooting for you we love
you all we can do is give love and
support those around us yeah here here
man that's all I have to say cheers
brother so good I'm out of wine reports
madam or are you completely out of boost
did you film out bottle my bottle is
empty holy [ __ ] you did that all
yourself I did I'm prize Tim Tim Tom oh
I'm telling keV keV people are saying
Tom is lit right now Oh Tom is lit no
doubt cheers everybody
we love you everybody seriously stay
safe out there
thank you so much for tuning in I hope
this gave you some laughs and and some
good times and we'll talk soon
you